big deal that simple things what my
favorite quotes it's a mathematic quote
but a mathematician you might have heard
of a German guy named Carl Gauss now
said this and his point was his point
was that sometimes simple objects like
it's very tempting to just say ah
there's not much to this there's not
much to this this is something you've
seen before have we not exhausted this
from the insights that we can get out of
it or the things that we can do with it
and the answer is no no we have
absolutely not exhausted all the
insights we can get all right yes it's a
very simple shape all you need to do is
throw an object through the air and
you'll make a parabola like it's a very
very simple object and yet there are so
many things we can discover about it ok
so that's the first point in why we look
at this secondly we're gonna go further
into calculus later we've just done the
bare introduction of it many of the
quadratics we're going to look at partly
because they're accessible and so we can
look at them movie builds upon or will
lead to quadratics right so in some ways
this is a bit of a pragmatic sort of way
to think about it you're going to be
using lots of quadratics in the future
even more than you already have
so it is very much in your interest to
sort of be able to say yep that's not
even something I'm thinking about like
when you you know are having a
conversation with someone you don't have
to think about what are the meaning of
the words coming in the mouth
you know what they all are and that's
where you can construct it comes
conversation with someone right you
don't want to have to be thinking about
oh what's the way this quadratic works
am I doing this right
you want that to be a given so you can
focus on the other stuff so you can make
a conclusion about the the part of an
object through the air or the derivative
that you're looking at or whatever it is
so that's two reasons why we're looking
at this we did circle geometry
I drew diagram we labeled it with the
record radix so here's a problem and
we're gonna label it give me a feature
that we can label on this dude yeah
vertex okay where's the vertex I've
drawn this as concave up i concave is a
word you used to hear you to do lenses
right so he's he's the concave
it's gone that way okay so that means
the vertex is right at the bottom deal
it's like what I got you something else
wrap okay the axis search is a great
place to go because as you notice number
one all parabolas are symmetrical but
number two the vertex is right on that
axis of symmetry okay because of the way
that I've drawn my quadratic my axis of
symmetry is vertical but it doesn't have
to be it could be sideways and what you
would get is a parabola that is also
sideways okay great vertex access a
century what else he told me yep okay
I've got I've got some intercepts
tonight okay
and I've purposely drawn them in
different spots
so there's the x-intercept there's
there's a way to set okay
now B that we're getting some on
concrete features on here we came to a
manatee parabola right so I'm gonna call
this a general problem what's the
general form of the equation of a
parabola right now great ax squared plus
BX plus C now once you know that you
already know a whole bunch of the
features on here at for instance that
y-intercept that way intercept over
there you already know it's coordinates
right they're very simple they're very
support throughout it the y-intercept
exists when x equals 0 right so when x
equals 0 this guy disappears and this
guy disappears and all you get left with
is a constant term right so this is
actually 0 see that's the coordinate of
your y-intercept I could write the
coordinates of the X intercepts on there
as well but because it's a general one
I'm gonna have the messy quadratic
formula on there but I will get that
later on okay now if I know this I also
in no way this day is right where's the
access to certainty remember the formula
yes
x equals yep good x8
- field to a in this case and as I said
we had a sideways parabola we have a y
equals - Bo - area but you get the idea
okay are there any other things that you
can talk about this yeah all okay I
could put the gradient function on here
couldn't I if I did do the gradient
function I had looked good because I
think I'm a cloud the diagram it's nice
in the admit but um it would be what
kind of function I this is a parabola so
what was the great it look like it would
be a straight line because this is
degree two you differentiate once what
is I could just simply write the
derivative obviously or to be equal to B
okay see there's just straight right
it's going to be think about this guy
right this derivative is going to be
equal to zero at what point it's it's on
there right at this point here which is
actually goes - Bo - a right and you can
think about it when you put minus B on
to a and they're the two ways kids so
you get minus B plus B so the derivative
is zero which is exactly what you see
okay so it's gonna be a line that goes
through there their grade would be zero
at that point I think that's enough for
now